I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- So it's my senior
year of college
and I've got really hot
Saturday night plans.
Order Chinese takeout
and then eat it.
I looked in the bag
and there was no fork.
(buzzer humming)
And there were no chopsticks.
There was no vehicle
with which the
Singapore rice noodles
could travel into my mouth.
(chips crunching)
So, in a blind rage,
I sent an e-mail
to what I thought was my dorm.
Hey guys, does anyone
have a fork I can use?
But I sent it to
my entire school.
(air horn blaring)
The backlash was immediate.
Ding, ding, ding.
(bell ringing)
Everywhere I have
notifications telling me
to go fork myself.
Someone responded, yeah,
I have a fork you can use.
Someone else
responded unsubscribe.
And that was a freshman
who responded that.
That is like as alpha move.
Then later, someone posted,
is it really necessary
to e-mail the entire
school about a fork?
Which, as you know, is
the thing that I did.
That one got 200 likes.
And then somebody else responded
to it, saying, seconded.
Literally just saying I agree.
Which is, by the way,
what a like does.
That go 100 likes.
People saw that first post
and were like, yeah, mad.
And then they saw that second
post that just said, uh huh,
and they were like,
yeah, I'm even madder.
So, uh, I guess my protip
here would be
if you want to unite
a lot of people,
send them all an e-mail.
They'll hate you, but they'll
grow to love each other.
(bell dings)